the cruise industry
is testing the waters in its return
in the us cruise ships are currently
sailing at a lower capacity
with many of these ships requiring
passengers to be vaccinated but even
then
there have been kobe 19 cases detected
even among
vaccinated passengers so the cruise
industry has lost
billions of dollars since the pandemic
forced these companies to
cancel voyages more than a year in the
u.s
and during that time they laid off
thousands of employees and
curtailed marketing expenses in order to
stay afloat
and for now these operators are slowly
generating revenue
as they take in their first passengers
[Music]
but they have also budgeted hundreds of
millions of dollars
in additional costs for measures such as
enhanced sanitation
and covet 19 testing for crew
so the cruise industry has faced some
challenges as they return
in the us and the first that they all
need to tackle
right away is to regain customer
confidence
after having various outbreaks on their
ships early in the pandemic such as the
diamond princess
outbreak in japan and to counter that
they would have to employ all these
sanitation measures and
safety protocols in order to reassure
their passengers that
cruising is safe
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the cruise lines have been bound to the
set of
guidelines and recommendations laid out
by the cdc
since october 2020 and one way that
they're able to sail is to ensure that
most of the people on board
are vaccinated so even though having at
least
95 percent of people on board vaccinated
is
a quick way for the cruise lines to
resume ceilings in the u.s
it's not that straightforward because in
one of the states where they operate
florida which is a major cruise hub
there is a law in place that
prohibits businesses from asking
their patrons for proof of vaccination
and
these cruise lines generally want their
passengers to be
vaccinated as a result this issue has
led to
lawsuits involving the cdc the state of
florida and also one cruise operator
some key indicators of success for
cruise lines
in the near term is to avoid having
massive chronovirus outbreaks on board
because
that was one of the main reasons why
their sailings had to be halted
early in the pandemic the new
coronavirus variants
ultimately poses a risk to the broader
hospitality sector and
that includes cruise lines and their
full effect has yet to be seen
on these first few sailings the timing
for when
cruise operators could return to
pre-pandemic normalcy
is pretty uncertain although cruz
executives have repeatedly cited pent-up
demand for
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
voyages